bonjour à tous
donc je viens pour vous présenter notre
projet notre entreprise blackfoot alors
blackfoot comme l'a dit luca c'est un
laps de prototypage un lob de
prototypage qui a la volonté d'exercer
dans le domaine des objets étaient
connectés pardon et des nouvelles
technologies en général a pour vous
donner quelques références de personnes
avec qui on travaille par exemple ce
sont des industriels comme le groupe
bric à peu près toutes ces filières que
ce soit construction immobilier
opérateurs télécoms ou alors encore des
entreprises d'état comme la poste par
exemple avec qui nous avons envoyé un
prototype au csa las vegas ça c'est une
de nos fiertés
donc voilà on fait du prototypage bon ok
mais c'est quoi exactement un prototype
alors ça c'est la timeline d'un projet
on passe par de l'idéation puis une
phase de prototypage
ça c'est pour nous et ensuite on va vers
de l'industrialisation dans le
prototypage on va retrouver le poc poc
proof of concept preuve de concept en
france et c'est là où on valide la
faisabilité technique d'un projet
ensuite vient le m veepee donc le
produit minimum viable donc c'est à dire
la première itération du produit qui a
une valeur ajoutée pour l'utilisateur le
premier produit qu'on peut tester auprès
de l'utilisateur
donc pour vous expliquer blackfoot
évidemment son rôle est dans la phase de
prototypage beaucoup aussi à l'idéation
est de plus en plus ce qu'on veut faire
c'est pousser la limite à droite pour
aller vers de l'industrialisation
alors donc je vous ai expliqué ce que
selon nous était un prototype à je vous
ai parlé d' avec qui on travaille et je
vais vous raconter quelques projets fun
de nos débuts ça c'est le projet qu'on a
appelée l'hoverboard pourquoi parce
qu'il est basé sur un hoverboard en fait
on a rencontré à nos clients qui
travaillent dans l'audiovisuel et il
avait une problématique il avait besoin
d'un chariot de travelling à chaque lot
de travelling qui est capable de
déplacer très longuement manière très
fluide une charge très lourde pour
mettre un gros risque de caméras faire
de la captation à 360 degrés donc nous
on s'est dit bon ok comment on va faire
et là on a pensé à l'hoverboard qui
déplace des personnes de manière fluide
puisqu'elle ne tombe pas et qui sont
lourdes qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 80
voire 90 kg et en termes de prix un
objet grand public sur des très grandes
séries produites dans une usine dans des
usines en chine
on fera jamais mieux donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est venu avec ça un autre projet
dont un petit peu dans la même veine
mais quand même différent on attend
parmi kindt elle avait développé une
nouvelle puce avec laquelle on a
travaillé qu'on a beaucoup aimé et il
cherche des démonstrations de l' usage
de cette puce donc nous comment on
répond à ça eh ben on se dit ok très
bien on va aller dans un magasin de
jouets on achète une voiture
télécommandée vraiment le truc pour les
enfants et on enlève à peu près tout ce
qu'il ya dedans on jette à la poubelle
la télécommande et en rajoute la fameuse
puce dans la voiture alors ça qu'est ce
que ça fait à la puce on lui connecter
une caméra là elle propage son propre
réseau wifi donc ça veut dire que d'à
peu près n'importe où dans le monde
on peut se connecter à la voiture la
télécommande et et donc elle pourrait
être là au fond de l'auditoire je
pourrais la télécommande et d'ici et on
verrait par exemple sur le slide le
retour vidéo
donc ça on leur a présenté on leur a
montré on l'a même présenter un concours
sur internet où on a été nominé parmi
les lauréats on leur a montré un petit
peu en rigolant disant bat et on a gagné
un concours
donc on pense que c'est cool et uil ont
trouvé ça vraiment super chouette que
c'était une superbe démonstration de
leurs produits et donc qu'est ce que ça
a fait but ils nous ont acheté en fait
deux prototypes 1 pour l'envoyer sur des
salons à la maker faire à rome si sa
part à certains et d'autres un salon au
japon donc en plus de pouvoir dire qu'on
a des prototypes qui sont partis un peu
partout dans le monde mais en plus on
les a vendues à intel qui est quand même
l'inventeur de l'architecturé qui fait
tourner tous les pc dans le monde et ça
en tant que développeur logiciel pour
nous c'est quand même aussi une fierté
pour parler de quelque chose d'un peu
plus industrielles on va parler du drone
on est pas mal actif aussi sur ce
domaine notamment dans le secteur de
l'industrie et spécialement dans
l'inspection industrielle et d'énergie
en fait ils utilisent beaucoup le médium
du drone par contre ça représente pas
mal de problèmes le boulot de pilotage
est généralement assez compliqué et
surtout que le pilotage du drone s'est
jamais la finalité c'est janet cas
moyens le but
au final c'est de faire généralement une
captation vidéo la plus propre possible
d'éventuels défauts sur les
installations industrielles
donc nous ce qu'on a fait on a acheté un
drone qui existe dans le commerce qui a
la particularité d'être open source donc
on peut modifier
on a modifié son code on a imprimé le
boîtier en 3d qu'on voit ici on a
rajouté un capteur qu'on a conçu donc en
gros maintenant le drone il fait de
l'analyse optique ça lui permet de se
stabiliser latéralement on a un
télémètre laser qui renvoie une distance
par rapport à notre sac ça lui permet
aussi de se stabiliser en distance donc
en fait ce qu'on fait
rend pas vraiment les drones autonome
par contre on assiste le pilotage pour
permettre aux opérateurs de se focaliser
sur leur métier donc ça c'était quelques
exemples de proto pour que vous puissiez
les illustrer j'ai toujours parlé de
nous alors nous on sait qui c'est arthur
cemac livre ça c'est moi c'est
pierre-marie c'est kevin mais pas que
c'est aussi des collaborateurs des
salariés des stagiaires des freelancer
donc pour vous donner quelques chiffres
blackfoot a pour l'instant moins d'un an
fêterait son anniversaire au mois
prochain et nous sommes l'équivalent de
sept temps plein et une dizaine de
freelancer à peu près donc maintenant je
vais vous parler un petit peu de la
jeunesse de notre rencontre nous sommes
rencontrés au sein d'un cursus intensif
sur le campus technologique de paris-sud
à epitech et ce cursus il a une
particularité c'est qu'il fonctionne en
mode projet donc le mode projet qu'est
ce que ça veut dire mais en fait c'est
ça on a un projet on doit effectuer un
rendu et on apprend entre les deux
généralement les éléments sont inversés
on apprend puis on fait un projet et on
fait le rendu nous on apprend en faisons
et ça ça a été fondateur pour nous c'est
à ce moment là qu'on a compris qu'on a
su ce qu'on voulait faire c'était
réaliser des projets comme ça et à
prendre en les faisant et a dressé un
large marché maintenant on sait que ce
sont des prototypes
alors maintenant je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi à mon sens ce prototype et est
synonyme d' innover et qu'innover
implique forcément de prototype et à
quand nous nous sommes rencontrés donc
je vous le disais au sein d'un cursus
intensifs et qui avait la particularité
de représenter une immersion importante
on s'est dit ok on sait ce qu'on veut
faire on a compris mais on sait pas
forcément comment donc ce qu'on a fait à
ce moment là on s'est installé dans une
colocation tous les quatre un loft de
150 m² aussi au sud de paris et dans
l'idée donc de retrouver cette immersion
et de faire des avancées très rapide sur
le projet est de créer un esprit qu'on
appelle deux tribus ouverte et agile
donc pourquoi je vous raconte ça parce
que continent l'arrivée dans ce loft il
y avait des travaux à faire les
luminaires n'étaient pas tous installés
entre eux par exemple et donc on s'est
dit ok on veut faire des projets qu'est
ce qu'on ferait bien dans notre loft ben
on va connecter d'autres
maison donc par exemple on a installé
des capteurs sur les portes pour
détecter l'ouverture la fermeture des
serrures connecté pour pouvoir les
ouvrir et les fermer
on a connecté les lumières tout
contrôler on a un moteur de
reconnaissance vocale on a des scénarios
on peut déclencher le café pourquoi on
se lance le matin au caire ont été
hissés cool mais là on effectue déjà des
apprentissages important on apprend
qu'il est essentiel de confronter ces
hypothèses parce que nous ce qu'on
connaît bien à ce moment là c'est le
développement logiciel
les bugs on y est relativement habitués
ont fait une première observation en
tant que développeur c'est que les bugs
quand c'est dans sa maison s'est tout de
suite insupportable donc c'est juste pas
possible
on apprend aussi des notions
d'expérience utilisateur comme ça on en
parle beaucoup pour les applications
mais je vous assure que dans une maison
c'est particulièrement vrai on a une
idée on se dit on va faire des
interrupteurs sans fil on pourra
vraiment coûté une bonne idée on se dit
ok on va se mettre devant le film qu'on
lance le film on peut l'éteindre on n'a
même pas besoin de se lever on peut
rallumer tous ces pratiques en fait le
problème de ça c'est qu'on sait jamais
où l interrupteur et qu'on le retrouve
jamais on passe sa vie à chercher un
interrupteur c'est chiant c'est sûrement
pas une solution de remplacement
et ça nous a pris aussi autre chose
c'est à nous exposer donc déjà à cette
époque là heureusement on avait le
réflexe de s'exposer d'exposer nos
projets auprès de nos partenaires pour
qu'ils voient ce qu'on fait qu'on voit
si ça pouvait générer quelque chose donc
on leur explique on a déjà ce moment là
un contact privilégié avec le groupe
bouygues et donc on explique on a la
chance de rencontrer le directeur du
centre de recherche et développement
concernant la maison connectée en plein
dedans on lui montre tout ce qu'on a
fait et sait on voit le moteur de
reconnaissance vocale
ça fonctionne bien mais bon ils le
voient pas pour tout de suite et on lui
montre une dernière petite chose dit bah
tiens vu qu'on a complètement
redévelopper l'interface qui assure la
la boxe de domotique et qu'on a fait
quelque chose de différent on va te le
montrer c'est marrant on pense que c'est
un peu c'est pas forcément hyper utile
mais c'est rigolo à voir ce qui est
possible de faire et on lui montre le
fait qu'on a modélisé notre loft
complètement en 3d et que dans
l'interface
on peut venir cliquez sur les lampes les
allumer les éteindre ouvrir la porte et
c est là il ya quelque chose qui se
passe c'est tout de suite il embraye
dénoncer ça c'est exactement ce qu'il
nous faut nous on a un problème on crée
des appartements témoins on essaye de
faire venir nos clients nous
utilisateurs nos décideurs
on leur montre et le premier retour que
tout le monde nous fait c'est que les
les interfaces sur smartphone pour
contrôler sa mis sa maison et naviguer
dans des menus déroulants
c'est juste pas de jouer à personne n'a
envie de faire ça et ça par contre c'est
vraiment simple une interface en 3d
c'est intuitif et bien on démarre là
dessus et voilà comment on s'est
retrouvé à modéliser l'appartement
témoin de briques dans lequel vous voyez
il ya des lampes
on peut venir dessus donc là sur son
smartphone on clique on les allume les
états donc pourquoi je vous explique
tout ça à propos du fait que prototype
et ça implique que innover implique de
prototype et donc on s'est rendu compte
de choses que les bugs n'était pas
tolérable
donc on pense que le prototypage c'est
un langage commun un langage commun un
langage universel
ça permet aux techniciens de faire donc
là on comprend qu'il peut y avoir des
bugs on voit un petit peu la
problématique sous tous ses aspects on
voit les possibilités on comprend mieux
qu'est-ce que ça permet d'autre ça
permet aussi aux dirigeants aux
décideurs de voir et de comprendre ça
permet de déclencher des choses et ça
permet enfin aux utilisateurs de push et
de tester de s'approprier le produit
bref ça permet à tout le monde de le
matérialiser dans son esprit ça a le
mérite de faire exister une idée et nous
on a observé que le prototype c'est un
véritable pouvoir de déclencheur à
absolument tous les niveaux donc
maintenant je viens de vous expliquer
pourquoi innover implique de prototyper
et pourquoi
c'est particulièrement pertinent de le
faire maintenant on observe que
l'écosystème a une maturité qui est
juste parfaite
on observe une ouverture et une
mutualisation des ressources
principalement je vais vous parler de 3
trip de trois types de ressources pardon
de l'intelligence de certains lieux et
de l'innovation elle mène donc de
l'intelligence pourquoi je parle de ça
parce qu'on observait on est tous au
courant une explosion des réseaux
numériques
on peut trouver de la documentation des
exemples des discussions intéressantes à
peu près n'importe quel sujet technique
ça pour blackfoot c'est quand même la
matière première donc c'est hyper
intéressant
en plus on a observé une grosse vague
d'arrivées de logiciels libres avec le
bonne source principe qui s'est
généralisée à l'électronique donc
l'électronique manon s'est ouverte avec
la vague de l'open hardware donc ça
signifie quoi qu'on peut acheter sur
étagère des cartes prototype et avec
honteux jour on les reçoit ont fait le
prototype le prototype ça va vite
si on a besoin de l'adapter don lever
des composants on les enlève on
redessine les plans ont l'air est en
voie on n'a rien
ce réalisme donc techniquement c'est
possible et on a le droit de les
revendre donc ça c'est quand même aussi
hyper utile ce qu'on a observé comme
ouverture ce sont les lieux et ça c'est
particulièrement vrai à paris on peut
trouver plein de fab lab pour l'usiné à
peu près toutes les pièces dont on veut
qu'on veut donc ce sont des lieux où il
ya des grosses machines on peut découper
au laser on peut couper du bois du métal
ont peut-être nos formes et du plastique
on peut imprimer en 3d on peut faire à
peu près tout ce qu'on veut il y avait
également des accélérateurs des
incubateurs on pourra rencontrer des
partenaires des mentors et d'autres
lieux qui sont plus divers mais aussi
aux nombreux comme les salons les meet
up les conférences et plein d'autres on
peut rencontrer des gens travailler son
réseau et continuer à apprendre
donc je vous parlais aussi de
l'innovation elle même en effet les
grands groupes actuellement n'innove
plus tout seuls dans leur coin il
continue à innover en mode recherche et
développement avec des plans mais par
contre ils ouvrent leurs innovations
dont qu'ils organisent des tables rondes
il rencontre des partenaires
ils ne veulent plus fermés aux idées
donc forcément ça un nouveau pour black
ops est mignon on est à peine une
société a&g d'un nom on peut parler avec
plein de grands groupes des industriels
qui ont des gros capitaux des vrais
moyens d'investissement et des vraies
capacités de développement des idées ça
c'est quand même intéressant donc vous
ai parlé maintenant de ce qu'on est et
je vais vous parler de notre vision pour
le futur
donc on a créé blackfoot baker salade de
prototypage maintenant notre mission à
court ou moyen terme c'est de créer
blackfoot studio et l'enjeu blackfoot
studio c'est de créer plusieurs petites
cellules d'innovation indépendante donc
des start up
pourquoi on fait ça parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que grâce au lac de
prototypage on a travaillé notre
expérience sur différents types de
marché avec différents types de
collaborations sur une plage assez large
de technologie donc comment on va faire
pour lancer sa et bien on va s'adosser
avec un partenaire qui de préférence à
des capitaux qui rencontre un besoin on
va développer ce besoin pour le lit et
après on va le vendre de manière globale
en marque blanche
donc voilà je vous ai expliqué que nous
avions déjà pris un modèle pour
évidemment reconstruire le nôtre qui est
celui ci qui est celui qu'on espère
évidemment une fois qu on a reconstruit
un modèle il faut être capable de
rejouer le même jeu il faut pouvoir se
mettre en perspective et pouvoir le
faire évoluer lorsque cela sera
nécessaire
donc voila merci de m'avoir écouté
j'espère que vous aurez compris
l'intention de mon discours qui était de
vous expliquer que innover implique
prototyper et que pour sa blague foutais
là merci
[Applaudissements]